for the third year in a row we're taking
our show down to San Diego for Comic Con
your name is so tense and poised trying
to escape I'm its yellow pin we're gonna
be airing a week that's right a week of
shows live from the Spreckels Theatre in
San Diego and there's that beautiful
through a billion theater yep it's proof
we've got lots of exciting stuff planned
and great guests including the cast of
HBO's Game of Thrones
isn't that amazing yeah that's pretty
amazing
also the cast of the new lego ninjago
movie starring Justin Theroux Olivia
Munn dave Franco Kumail Nanjiani and the
upcoming a Netflix movie bright starring
Will Smith Joel Edgerton and numerable
Pass is going to be we have the cast of
a movie that is so top secret I am not
allowed to divulge it right now that's
gonna be a secret yeah oh come on I just
gave you three what's your problem
it's all happening Wednesday July 19th
through Sunday July 23rd that's next
Wednesday through Sunday and this year
we're doing something new at Comic Con
that really excites as well as terrifies
me every night we're gonna do a one-hour
live pre-show before we go on the air
that's right we do a nightly one-hour
countdown to our show live from the
majestic roof of this Spreckels theater
and check out that road Wow yeah as
roofs go that's a really beautiful one
nice now the free shows will be hosted
by comedians Chris red and Moses storm
aka red storm they're gonna be hosting
these who will ping among three cameras
so you'll get to see our celebrity
guests hanging out our crew and staff
scrambling to get the show on the air or
just screwing up a pre-show visit from
me Plus all sorts of fan giveaways and
games and here's the best part the
entire life pre-show will be broadcast
in 360 degree virtual reality a
technology we call conan 360
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
which once again is being made possible
by our friends at AT&T you can watch all
the virtual reality pre shows on our
team cocoa Facebook and YouTube channels
and at team cocoa calm / 360 we will see
you at Comic Con next week
you